a couple of days ago CS2 players woke up
to countless posts urging them not to
play the game why well because massive
exploits were found ones that could put
porn on your screen remove items from
your inventory or literally even dox you
it's supposedly been fixed but is it
really safe to play
now valve has had a pretty rough week or
so on top of the ongoing false bands I
recently reported on and the massive
wave that saw thousands of Innocence
banned things got even worse Monday
Morning Post started circulating of a
massive security issue within CS2
allegedly users figured out it was
possible to change your steam IDs to
entire HTML blocks these could be links
to pictures or even gifts and apparently
since CS 2's in-game voting system isn't
properly sanitized they would show you
the actual images and not the line of
text I didn't fully understand this so
thankfully a Dev here at the score gave
me an explanation and a pretty good
example the HTML of an image on Google
shows up like this and when something
like a browser sees the code it will
interpret it and show the image rather
than that code a game like CS2 would
want to be sanitized so they would
Escape it basically meaning change
certain characters so they know not to
interpret the image but instead just
keep it as the code but since they
didn't if you made your name the link to
gore or pornographic images that's what
would show up on screen if you started
something like a vote obviously child as
but as this is the Cs Community it's
pretty par for the course and from what
I've been told a massive oversight on
valve's part some of the same accounts
that were warning about this issue in
the first place also claim that this
exploit could be used to grab IP
addresses of teammates who see the vote
window sure I Now understand how not
properly escaping a code could end up
showing an entire image instead of just
the HTML block I sort of connected to
how back in Source valve let you make
your spray literally whatever you wanted
and for most people that was usually
porn but how does that somehow equal
players getting their IP addresses
leaked well along with the dev from the
score to get a better understanding of
all of this I reached out to prolific
CS2 data Miner Aquarius to help me
understand and it's actually quite
simple every image that exists on the
Internet is stored on a server somewhere
and whenever your machine views that
image your IP address needs to access
that server so in the context of what's
going on in CS2 since the image popped
up in your game and not the line of text
your computer is basically forced to
access that server and if someone were
using an IP logger at the same time they
would t Al be able to view yours sounds
freaky right well that's exactly what a
lot of people posting about this were
thinking too including hacker and game
developer Jason Thor Hall who not only
urged people to not play the game but
claimed it could lead to an xss attack I
would not play CS right now I would not
do it you are 100% vulnerable to this
until they fix it do not play that game
right now and it is coming from a
security expert I've been a hacker for
20 years this is incredibly easy to pull
off you don't want this you don't want
this at all in an EXs app or cross-site
scripting attack a user could
potentially use malicious script that
could get onto your computer whenever
the vote pops up if that was true this
would be a massive security exploit for
valve but after testing Aquarius claims
it wasn't actually possible because
script tags weren't working in this
exploit in fact Aquarius and plenty of
other people believe this entire
situation was blown out of proportion
yes he agreed that people shouldn't play
the game until it was fixed but since an
xss attack wasn't actually possible he
figured the exploit was actually pretty
innocuous that's because it required a
lot of Randomness for a stranger to get
into a lobby with you log your IP and
then do something nefarious with it
others obviously disagreed and many
criticized valve for not actually
speaking on the issue however while all
of this was going on another exploit was
discovered one that Aquarius claimed was
in fact a big deal it turns out that it
was possible for Workshop maps to have
scripts on them that could apply and
scratch off stickers as well as remove
cases from your inventory it wasn't
possible for entire skins to get deleted
but as We Know tickers and cases can be
just as valuable fortunately regardless
of how you feel about the actual danger
of them both these exploits were removed
fairly quickly how do we know this well
it's sure as hell not because valve told
us I mean [__] a statement they didn't
even release patch notes for this
literally the only reason we know it's
safe to play again is because people
like Aquarius and gay follower figured
it out listen maybe this wasn't a big
deal after all maybe it was I personally
don't like the idea of someone having
access to my IP address or [__] with
my inventory but it seems that the
moment like nothing bad actually
happened to anyone still at the very
least this is a little embarrassing for
valve from what I've heard this is like
user security 101 and for them to miss
it is pretty concerning does that mean
that valve needed to make a big
statement addressing this issue I don't
know how I feel about that one but for f
sake at least some patch notes sure this
is quickly becoming a distant meme now
but it's also just another incident
adding to all the bad PR they faced
since launch now with all of that said
is it actually safe to play CS2 again
well at the moment apparently so but
seeing as we wake up to some more
[__] every single day I'd recommend
checking Twitter ever so
often I played yesterday and uh just I
got your IP address it came you got my
you got my IP address yeah I actually
already changed it
so share of luck but yeah I played I
played yesterday cuz I figured it was
safe and then uh Lobby's just filled
with cheaters so I started playing the
finals and that was more fun